and this movie was a trailblazer first
of all many people in the world millions
of people thought of the Nazis thugs
murderers people who had no education
this film set to the world these were
very intelligent people as Albert
Einstein once said I'm not afraid he
said of the anti-semites I'm afraid of
the good people who see it happening and
do nothing and when you see Burt
Lancaster a man of you portrays the good
judge who had morals who had ethics who
had integrity but who gave Hitler free
pass one of the witnesses brought to
Nuremberg was Rudolf Hoess commandant of
Auschwitz a psychiatrist was assigned to
all of the prisoners Leonard goldenson
and he went in to see Haase and he said
how many Jews how many people did you
murder at Auschwitz he said about two
million and he said did you live there
with your wife and children they said
yes so he said to us how did what was
life like did you have newspapers
delivered to your home he said sure we
have newspapers we regularly received
newspapers from Germany he said was your
favorite newspaper the storm ah which is
the Julia strike of the vicious
anti-semitic newspaper and the Huss
looked at him and he said oh no we'd
never permit a newspaper like that in
our house it was it was untruthful it
was full of propaganda and full of lies
so the psychiatrist sent him but you
just told me that you admit that you
murdered two million people in Auschwitz
and you did not take in the Sherma he
said no decent people would never take
the stormer and that's what Burt
Lancaster represented in the film he
said forget about the thought
Hitler would have been a nobody without
the intellectuals seven of the 14 people
present that van say that agree to the
plan of gassing the Jews were phd's
that's what drew the judgment at
Nuremburg said to the world it was the
intelligent people that deserved the
guilt in 1958 Elie Wiesel wrote his book
on night was translated into English
survivors hardly spoke about it but
enough books were then being published a
people were curious how is it possible
how could they gas 16,000 people a day
in Auschwitz and when judgment at
Nuremberg came out and the promos came
out that they were going to deal with
the subject of the concentration camps
and a curiosity people from all over you
know came to see this film and another
amazing thing it's hard to make a film
three hours and 10 minutes and they have
people sitting in the audience that
don't move it takes a genius of a
director and an outstanding cast nobody
in Hollywood today very few people would
attempt to make a three hour and ten
minute movie and think that they're
going to get away with it
you